Speaker 1: It's great to have back on the
program today Dr. Isaac Bogot, an infectious
diseases physician and scientist based out
of the University of Toronto and Toronto General
Hospital.
Great having you back again.
Speaker 4: Great to see you again.
Speaker 1: So where to even start?
OK, I mean, over the last over the last month
or so, we've seen a global decline of about
30, 31, 32 percent and daily case average.
The U.S. has seen a similar decline.
Some countries are a little bit ahead of that,
some a little bit behind.
What's the explanation here?
Is it vaccination getting to a critical point?
Is there still some seasonality?
We don't understand.
Is it just inaccurate reporting and maybe
cases aren't really going down?
Speaker 4: Yeah, I think I think it's a lot
of the above, in fact, all of the above.
So certainly in countries that have significant
vaccine access and vaccine rollout, that's
definitely helping.
Right.
That's definitely keeping cases down or driving
cases down.
And we can't ignore that.
But of course, there's probably other factors
at play.
We know that vaccine equity, global vaccine
equity is a major issue.
There still are billions of people around
the world without access to these vaccines,
mainly in low income countries.
And there are, you know, depending on where
you are in the world, there are very significant
outbreaks and epidemics of this.
So globally, it's great to see those cases
go down.
I think it's too soon to start having, you
know, mission accomplished banners up or anything
like that.
We're still at a global level, far from the
end.
But certainly in countries with high vaccine
uptake, like the United States, like Canada,
like many European countries and the few countries
in Asia, yeah, we are closer to the end.
We might be in the second or third period
rather than in the first period like some
other countries are.
Speaker 1: So last summer of twenty twenty,
there was the correct belief that the fall
into winter in the Northern Hemisphere was
going to get pretty bad.
At the time we were just starting to roll
out vaccines.
There was very limited availability.
The peak ended up being in the U.S.
It was basically January 20th, right around
presidential inauguration day.
In other countries, it was a little bit earlier,
a little bit later.
And then we saw the sort of big decline and
then we got the Delta spike this time around
where vaccination is available in many of
these countries.
And we're still not totally sure about the
seasonality match up that that sort of mirrors
the flu's seasonality.
What do we think about this fall in winter
in the Northern Hemisphere?
Speaker 4: I think there's a couple of points.
One is that when we talk about seasonality,
it might mean different things to different
people.
And yes, I'm sure eventually this virus will
have a more seasonal component.
Maybe it'll be more present in certain times
of year, like the colder months versus the
warmer months.
And that's that's very likely to happen with
time.
But when I'm talking about seasonality now,
I'm I'm oversimplifying it.
But it kind of can be simplified in the sense
that whatever puts people indoors is is a
is a risk factor for greater transmission.
Hey, it's cold outside and it's September.
So kids are going back to school.
Many people are going back to work in person.
And we're not hanging out outdoors any as
much anymore because it's getting chilly.
We're spending recreational time indoors.
And that in and of itself at a population
level can certainly drive numbers up because
there's just innumerable opportunities for
this virus to be transmitted.
So when we put that together and look at the
northern hemisphere, yes, it is getting cooler.
People are going inside for more and more
reason.
I think it's fair to say that we will see
peaks and valleys, but probably peaks throughout
the cooler months and the fall in the winter
in the northern hemisphere.
And, you know, sort of stating the obvious.
I think areas that have more widespread vaccine
uptake will have more blunted peak.
So the amplitude of those peaks is really
under our control in countries like Canada,
the United States, that are fortunate enough
to have access to those vaccines.
You can vaccinate yourself and those around
you in your community.
You can create safer indoor spaces as well
with masking, with ventilation, with crowd
control.
Like there's a lot of steps we can take to
create safer indoor spaces at a population
level as well, so that you reap the benefits
of of those vaccination campaigns plus those
non pharmaceutical interventions.
So short story long.
Yeah, I mean, we'll probably have some peaks
and valleys throughout the fall, in the winter,
but how high those peaks go are under our
control.
We have the tools to keep this under control
and so on.
Speaker 1: Speaking of tools, there was a
period where it seemed as though every adult
was headed towards a third shot.
Originally, the word booster was used.
But when it was when the framing was, no,
no, no, it may be a three shot regimen.
The change of language was it's not a it's
not a booster.
It's just part of what you're supposed to
do.
And then all of a sudden we started seeing
a change in tone to some degree, where at
least in the U.S., the recommendation change
to only third shots for 65 plus immunocompromised
preexisting conditions, which if you include
being overweight and smoking, is a lot of
people in the United States.
Right.
I mean, but let's let's put that aside just
for a second here.
What's your sense of because there's the medical
question as to who would really benefit.
There's a vaccine equity question as to should
people be getting third shots or is are those
better used as first shots in other parts
of the world?
How should we be thinking about it?
Speaker 4: David, I love how you separate
those questions, because oftentimes that gets
confused and from a medical standpoint, like
this is a very valid medical question.
Do people need a third dose of the vaccine?
And if we want to delve into that, I think
the answer is, like anything else, it's a
bit more complicated.
I think there's good data to drive that immunocompromised
individuals, however we want to define it,
would benefit from a third dose of a vaccine.
Right.
They just don't mount the same degree of an
immune response as other people.
And as you point out, this can be viewed as
you know, many people have had two doses of
a three dose regimen.
You need that third dose for better protection.
We've known this for a million years, well
before covid-19.
There's a reason we give immunocompromised
individuals double doses of, for example,
the hepatitis B vaccine like this is no similar
to that.
People who are on the older end of the spectrum
will probably benefit from a third dose of
a vaccine in the United States.
It was defined as sixty five and up.
We could argue and debate about the data,
but that's not unreasonable, including those
who live in Kongregate care settings like
long term care facilities.
And again, we've known this long before covid-19
came around.
There's a reason we give older cohorts the
higher dose influenza vaccine every year because
we know they need an extra boost to mount
an immune response.
But I got to say and, you know, when we're
you know, I'm sitting in Canada now when we
were listening to the United States discuss
this, if we were in mid-August, we heard very
senior political and public health leaders
say everyone's getting a booster shot at the
six month mark.
Oops.
Pardon.
Sorry, everyone is getting a booster at the
five month mark.
Oops.
No, no, we meant six months or eight months.
And then they actually had to sit down and
you had the FDA discuss it.
Then you had the vaccine experts discuss it,
like the process to get to this decision was
very choppy and I think did a lot of damage
in terms of public trust in the vaccine efforts,
especially when we know many unvaccinated
people currently.
You know, we're for lack of a better word,
we're trying to win them over.
We're trying to show and demonstrate how safe
and effective and reasonable it is to get
these vaccines.
This didn't do a lot of good in getting to
that point, unfortunately.
The other thing, too, is I don't know where
it really landed in the United States because
it seems like, you know, if you're a smoker,
if you're obese, if you may work in a higher
risk setting, you can get it basically seems
like it's open season and anyone who wants
to get a third dose can get a third dose.
I don't think that's that's really appropriate.
I'm not to blab on and on.
But then let's factor in the equity issue.
You've got hundreds of millions of people
that are eligible for a third dose when there's
billions of people who haven't received the
first dose and hundreds or tens of millions
of Americans that should be receiving a first
dose.
You want to get this under control, you get
first and second doses and as many people
as possible rather than third doses.
Not to ignore that there are some people who
would really benefit from a third dose.
So to sum it all up, do we all need third
doses now?
No, we don't.
Do some of us need third doses now?
Yes, some of us do.
Will we all need a third dose at some point
in the future?
Yeah, we might all need a third dose at some
point in the future, but we don't all need
to third dose now.
Speaker 1: So in terms of protection level,
which as you point out, can be in terms of
larger populations, the protection level is
lower for certain folks.
And that's a factor in thinking about these
third doses.
How should we be thinking now about how protected
one is today, given the difference between
the dominant Delta strain and what was the
original or live strain for which the vaccines
were calculated?
Because you hear you still got a mask if you're
vaccinated because you can still spread it.
And then you hear, hey, actually you can.
But if you're vaccinated and asymptomatic,
it's not super likely.
But it's but it's possible and it makes it
makes it very difficult to do like a risk
assessment of any individual.
So when you read 99, 98, 97 percent of the
cases and or at least hospitalizations are
in the unvaccinated, what does that tell us?
Speaker 4: Yeah, basically, you know, sometimes
people complain about shifting goalposts and
you're changing the rules.
And the answer is yes, of course they're shifting
goalposts.
Of course, you're changing the rules and adapting
policy.
You have to because the virus has changed
as well.
And the Delta variant is, of course, it's
the same virus, but it functions in a different
manner.
It's way more transmissible compared to the
original virus that emerged from Juhan.
So, yes, you have to have these shifting goalposts.
The problem is communicating this and and
telegraphing uncertainty and communicating
that there will be changes over time.
Some we can expect, some we not we might not
be able to expect so that people don't feel
like they're getting the rug pulled from underneath
them.
So that's that that's one important point.
The second point.
Yeah, I mean, Delta is much more transmissible,
but we do know that if you're vaccinated right
off the bat, Delta or not, especially even
with Delta, you still reduce the risk of getting
covid-19.
You reduce the risk of getting infected, but
you greatly reduce your risk of getting really
sick, like landing in hospital, needing an
ICU or dying.
And there's just overwhelming data from multiple
countries demonstrating all this.
The second point is you can still get infected
with Delta even if you're vaccinated.
We've known that.
We've known that long before Delta even emerged
in the original clinical trials that were
published, there were still vaccinated people
that got infected.
Delta hadn't even emerged yet.
So that's not new.
But we do know now that if you are vaccinated
and infected, you're just much less likely
to transmit to other people.
Of course, you can still transmit, but the
probability is lower.
So, you know, for example, if you want to
create a safe indoor space, a restaurant,
a bar, a casino, a day care, wherever, the
more vaccinated people you have that indoor
space, you just reduce a the likelihood that
you're bringing covid-19 into that space.
And B, if it is brought in the likelihood
that it's transmitted to other people, of
course, that's one significant layer of protection.
But we have to think of this as layers of
protection.
There's other layers you can take, masking,
ventilation, crowd control.
And when you put all those layers together
and you add that to vaccines, you want to
get really fancy at rapid testing at the door.
The more layers you have, the safer the indoor
space you have, the more layers you peel off.
You're just adding incremental levels of risk.
And you've got to find that sweet spot of
what's reasonable, what's convenient and what's
necessary for that particular environment.
Speaker 1: Last thing I want to touch on,
when do cases no longer matter?
In a very specific sense, I think it was with
H1N1 that at a certain point when it was determined
that it's no more deadly than the flu strain
of that year.
And correct me if it's not H1N1, but it was
a different thing that I'm referring to.
At a certain point, the testing stopped because
it didn't really matter whether you had the
flu or you had.
Again, I think it was H1N1 because the protocol
was no different.
It was no more deadly.
The case numbers may have been interesting,
but they didn't really tell us anything about
the risk to an individual of getting really
sick from being out in the world.
Does it depend on the level of vaccination?
Does it depend on the maybe reduced severity
of coronavirus as we go forward, which may
happen or it may not?
When do the case numbers no longer matter?
Speaker 4: So I think if you lined up 20 people
in the business, you'd probably get several
different answers.
The way I think about this, though, is I like
the case numbers, but it has to be put into
the appropriate context.
Right.
There's a lot of data hospitalizations, ICU
death cases vaccinated, percent positive,
blah, blah, blah, blah.
But context is important.
So you have to put the appropriate weight
and context to each data point.
But when the case numbers sort of start to
lower in the importance factor, I think it's
in my mind it's really when we start to see
this virus not impact our society as much
anymore.
What do you mean by that?
It's not resulting in an overwhelming number
of hospitalizations or deaths or morbidity.
It's not preventing people from doing what
they do.
And a lot of that's a value judgment as well,
right?
There's a value judgment here.
It's kind of unfortunate and disgusting to
think about.
But at some point we're going to have to collectively
decide what is an acceptable number of deaths
per year for covid-19.
Not nice to think about, but we have to figure
that out.
Like in Canada, for example, influenza kills
thirty five hundred people per year.
Awful, terrible.
Get your flu shot.
All of them are tragic.
But as a country, we've sort of come to terms
with facts about how many we see per year.
We have to come to terms with how many covid-19
deaths or cases or what is quote unquote acceptable.
And again, some will say zero.
I don't think that's practical.
Of course, there's the letter rip crowd.
I don't think that's safe or ethical as well.
But eventually enough people have immunity
through vaccination or recovery from infection
that it just doesn't pose a burden on the
country or the region as much as it used to.
You're not going to overwhelm your your health
care system.
You can go to restaurants and bars and live
your life, but the virus isn't going away.
So it's going to be a bit of a value judgment.
That's a bit of a long winded way of answering
that question.
But at some point, as long as it when it's
when it impacts the country or the region
less by not overwhelming the health care system
and not causing.
Meaningful morbidity and mortality, that's
probably when the case counts, don't matter.
Speaker 1: Yeah, and it will still be on a
different call for different individuals also
based on their their level of risk and their
willingness to accept risk as well.
So there's no it's a it's a complex answer
because it's a complex question, I guess,
is the way we would say it.
We've been speaking with Dr. Isaac Bogarde,
infectious diseases physician and scientist
based at the University of Toronto and Toronto
General Hospital.
Always great catching up with you.
Speaker 4: Great to chat, David